دعني ابدا معك بسؤال عن مشاركتك في منتدى
الرياض الثالث للمنتدى الدولي للاعمال
الانسانيه هذه المره الاولى التي يشارك
فيها شخص من برنامج الامم المتحده الانماء
بهذا المنصب الرفيع في منتدى انساني وليس
منتدى تنموي لماذا ما الذي يعنيه ذلك
النمرشن هناك العديد من الاسباب اولها
الدعوه التي تلقيتها من مركز الملك سلمان
للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
والتعاون المتنامي بيننا وبين المركز ما
سمح بان يصبح جزءا من نقاش واسع حول كيفيه
استجابتنا للازمات والنزاعات جرت العاده
ان تركز الاستجابه للازمه الانسانيه على
انقاذ حياه الناس والاسعاف السريع سواء
كان زلزال او حربا وازمه انسانيه والنزاعا
ولكنها بصفه متزايده اصبحنا نعيش في عالم
يشهد تناميا مضطردا للازمات والتي نسميها
الازمات الحمائيه حيث تتطلب تدخلا سريعا
لحمايه الاهالي حيث هناك الان ما لا يقل
عن 100 مليون شخص عبر انحاء العالم هم اما
لاجئون او ناجحون داخل اراضي دواليا ولذلك
فان برنامج الامم المتحده الاملائي هو
اليوم جزء من برنامج الامم المتحده
للاستجابه للازمات ومشاركتي الاخيره في
منتدى الرياض الدولي للعمل الانساني هو
شكل من الاعتراف باننا نعمل الان مع بعضنا
البعض بشكل اوثق من اي وقت مضى بهدف
التكامل بيننا والتعاون بشان كيفيه
التعامل مع هذه الازمات المزيد من التعاون
بينكم بين المملكه العربيه السعوديه في حل
هذه الازمات
هذا جزء منها لدينا الان برامج شراكه
للتعامل مع ازمات الناشبه في عده دول
ووقعنا خلال زياره اتفاقيتين اضافيتين
لتعزيز تعاوننا وعملنا المشترك في اليمن
لان ما النتائج الحرب هناك اننا نشهد
اليوم ضحايا اكبر خارج ميدان القتال
والنزاع من اعدادهم على ما يدين المعارك
سواء بسبب الجوع او الاوبئه وعدم القدره
على حمايه الناس وهو من المتطلبات
الاساسيه لاي دوله ولذلك فان قدرتنا على
تدريب الناس على كيفيه التعامل والتجاوز
هذا الظرف الرهيب عبر حزمه خدمات نقدمها
وهي جزء من برنامج استجابه تنمويه طارئه
نتعاون فيها مع مركز الملك سلمان